these days i hear the terms
observability monitoring and apm
or application performance management
thrown around seemingly interchangeably
but these terms actually mean quite
different things so let's dive in head
first and see an example of
how exactly these things differ so to
start i'm going to start with kind of a
java ee
application uh it's kind of old school
we'll
go back you know maybe a decade and
let's say that we've got some components
in this java ee app
that actually power it so something
important to remember here although we
might be using a soa or
service oriented architecture this is
not exactly microservices
so they're not communicating over rest
apis so you have some inherent
advantages here
for example you can take advantage of
like the the framework the java e
framework to
output log files which will probably all
come out into the same directory
and the timestamps match up so things
are good in addition you could take
advantage of something like an apm
solution which is kind of like a one
size fits all
set and forget so you install it and
it'll kind of get rich analytics and
data and
metrics about the running services
within the application
so essentially what we've done is we've
made our system observable
so that you know our ops teams were then
able to kind of look into it
and identify problems
and figure out you know if anything
needed to be done so for the business
objectives back then this was
essentially
good enough but this tends to fall apart
very quickly when you start to move to a
more cloud native approach where you
have multiple run times and multiple
kind of
layers to the architecture
so let's say we have an example app here
so we'll say we'll start with
node as a front end let's say we also
have
a java backend application
and then finally let's say we also have
a python app
which is doing some data processing so
let's see how these things
work with each other so the front end
app probably talks to the java app
and also the python app for some data
processing the java app probably
communicates with a database
and then the python app probably talks
to the java app for kind of crud
operations
so this is kind of my quick sketch uh
kind of a dummy
layout for a microservices based
application
you can take it a step further and even
say that this is all running
within kubernetes so we've got these
container-based applications running in
a cluster
so immediately the first problem i can
see here is that with multiple runtimes
we now have to think about multiple
different agents or ways to collect data
so instead of just one apm tool we might
have to start thinking about pulling in
multiple
so how would we con consolidate all that
data right so that's a challenge
in addition let's think about things
like logging so each of these runtimes
probably outputting logs in a different
place and
you know we have to figure out how we
consolidate all those maybe we use a log
streaming service
regardless you can see the complexity
starts to grow and finally as you add
more services and microservices
components to this architecture
say a user comes in where try to
actually access one of these services
and they run into an error
you need to trace that request through
the multiple services
well unless you have the right
architecture infrastructure in place
you know something like headers on
requests
maybe a way to handle websockets things
are going to start to get messy and you
can see how the technical complexity
grows quite large so here's where
observability comes in
and actually differs and defers itself
from kind of standard apm tools
it thinks about the more holistic cloud
cloud-native approach
for being able to do things like logging
and monitoring and that kind of thing
so i'll say there's three major steps
for any sort of observability solution
we'll start with the first one we'll
call it collect because we need to
collect data
then we'll go to monitor and we'll talk
about this because this is
you know part of monitoring and finally
we'll end with analyze
kind of doing something with the actual
data that you have
so with the collect step you know first
thing let's say that we actually made
our system observable
so the great thing is with kubernetes
you get some cpu memory data
automatically
so let's say we get some of that we get
some logs from the application
all streaming to the same location and
let's say we even get some other stuff
like
high availability numbers or average
latency
you know things that we want to be able
to track and monitor
so that brings me to my next step so
once we have this data available
we need to be able to actually do
something with it at least visualizing
it maybe if we're not actually even
solving problems yet
what do we do with this data well maybe
we create some dashboards
to be able to monitor the health of our
application
and say we create multiple dashboards to
be able to track
different services or kind of different
business objectives
high availability versus latency that
kind of thing
now the final thing that i want to talk
about here is what do we do next
so say we found some bug in the
application by
kind of looking at our monitoring
dashboards and we need to
dive in deeper and fix the problem with
the node app
well the great thing about that is an
observability solution should allow you
to do just that
it allows you to actually take it even a
step further because these days with
kubernetes
you're getting a lot of that information
from the kubernetes layer
so this is something i want to quickly
pause and talk about so with apm tools
in the past they were really
kind of focused on kind of like resource
constraints cpu usage
memory usage that kind of thing these
days that's been offloaded to the
kubernetes layer
so you know observability kind of took
apm and evolved it
to the next stage pulled it a step up
and enables our users to focus on things
like
slos and slis service level objectives
and service level indicators
so these will enable you to actually
focus on things that matter to your
business
so things like making sure that
latencies are low or that application
uptime is
high so i think that's kind of the
crucial three steps for any sort of
observability solution
let's take a step back again these
things can be hard to set up on your own
with open source projects and
capabilities pulling all the different
things together
so you might want might be looking at an
enterprise observability solution
and so when you're comparing competitors
and looking at building out your
enterprise observability capability
i would look at kind of three main
things
now let's start with automation
now every step of the way we need to
make sure that automation is there to
make things easier
so let's say that our dev team pushes
out a new version of the node app
and go from v1 to v2
now let's say they inadvertently
introduced a bug instead of making
a bulk api call they now make individual
api calls to the python
app so in our monitoring dashboard our
ops team's like oh guys something's
wrong
the db app is getting a lot of requests
what's going on
well you need to be able to kind of
automatically
go back and trace through the requests
and identify what happened
that actually brings me to my second
point as well which is context
it's always important i can spell to
have that context
so automation is important here because
when upgrading to the new version a node
you want to make sure that the right
agent is automatically installed and
kind of the instrumentation is in place
so your dev team doesn't quite have to
do that and
as new services get added you want your
monitoring dashboards to be
automatically updated as well
and that context is extremely crucial as
with this example we needed to be able
to trace that request back to the source
of the problem
so once we've traced that request back
to the source with that context that we
have
the third step here and i think probably
one of the most important
is action what do we actually do now
and that brings me to my last step here
the analyze phase
which remember we talked about was kind
of an evolution of traditional apm tools
to kind of the the way that
observability tools implement that today
so when you get to this step you'll
probably want to look at maybe the
that's the lies within the node app
maybe dive in deeper right so maybe you
look in and you identify
that you need to look at application
trace logs so you look in the trace logs
and you identify some problems and
you figure out what the what the fix is
you tell it to your dev team
you know maybe the last step here is fix
and then rinse and repeat for any other
issues that might come up in the future
so i think enterprise observability is
extremely crucial here when we're kind
of looking at
the bigger picture because it's not just
about having the individual pieces
which again like i said might be quite
hard to set up with purely open source
approaches
but you want to think about automation
to make sure things are
kind of set up seamlessly to reduce the
overhead on your side
make sure you have contacts to be able
to see how services work with each other
maybe even generate things like
dependency graphs to see
the broader view because you might not
always have a light board like this to
see the architecture so cleanly
and finally being able to take action
when you do find a problem
so making sure that your observability
solution has a way to automatically pull
together data from multiple sources
multiple services
and then figure out what's valid and
necessary for you to be able to
make that fix happen so ibm is invested
in making sure our clients can
effectively set up enterprise
observability
with the recent acquisition of instanta
to learn more about the acquisition or
to get a showcase of the capabilities
be sure to check out the links in the
description below
as always thanks for watching our videos
if you liked the video or have any
questions or comments be sure to drop a
like
and a question or comment below be sure
to subscribe and stay tuned
for more videos like this in the future
thank you